[Music]
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know
nothing the unexamined life is not worth
living there is only one good knowledge
and one evil
ignorance
[Music]
I cannot teach anybody anything I can
only make them
think wonder is the beginning of
wisdom be kind for everyone you meet is
fighting a hard
battle strong Minds discuss ideas
average Minds discuss events weak Minds
Minds discuss
people to find yourself think for
yourself education is the kindling of a
flame not the filling of a
vessel by all means Mary if you get a
good wife you'll become happy if you get
a bad one you'll become a
philosopher
be slow to fall into friendship but when
you are in continue firm and
constant he who is not content with what
he has would not be content with what he
would like to
have children today love luxury they
have Bad Manners contempt for Authority
they show disrespect for elders and love
chatter in places of
exercise sometimes you put walls up not
to keep people out but to see who cares
enough to break them
down know
thyself let him who would move the world
first move
himself when the debate is lost slander
becomes the tool of the
loser death may be the greatest of all
human
blessings the only good is knowledge the
only evil is
[Music]
ignorance contentment is natural wealth
luxury is artificial
poverty do not do to others what angers
you if done to you by
others every action has its pleasures
and its
price employ your time in improving
yourself by other men's writings so that
you shall come easily by what others
have labored hard
for no man has the right to be an
amateur in the matter of physical
training
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is
capable I am not an Athenian or a Greek
but a citizen of the
world prefer knowledge to wealth for the
one is transitory the other
Perpetual the hour of departure has
arrived
and we go our separate ways I to die and
you to live which of these two is better
only God
knows we cannot live better than in
seeking to become
better understanding a question is half
the
answer Envy is the ulcer of the
Soul
beware the bareness of a busy
life the hottest love has the coldest
end I know that I am intelligent because
I know that I know
[Music]
nothing be as you wish to
seem from the deepest desires often
comes the Dead EST
hate be nicer than necessary to everyone
you meet everyone is fighting some kind
of
battle thou shouldest Eat to Live not
live to
eat the greatest way to live with honor
in this world is to be what we pretend
to
be if you want to be a good Saddler
saddle the worst horse for if you can
tame that one you can tame them
[Music]
all true wisdom comes to each of us when
we realize how little we understand
about life ourselves and the world
around
us once made equal to man woman becomes
his
Superior
I pray thee Oh God that I may be
beautiful
[Music]
within the really important thing is not
to live but to live well and to live
well means along with more enjoyable
things in life to live according to your
principles one should never do wrong in
return nor mistreat any man no matter
how one has been mistreated by
[Music]
him life contains but two tragedies one
is not to get your heart's desire the
other is to get
it the easiest and noblest way is not to
be crushing others but to be improving
yourself if all our misfortunes were
laid in one common Heap whence everyone
must take an equal portion most people
would be content to take their own and
depart the beginning of wisdom is the
definition of
terms he is richest who is content with
the least for content is the wealth of
[Music]
nature in all of us even in Good Men
there is a lawless wild beast nature
which peers out in
[Music]
sleep my friend care for your psyche
know yourself for once we know ourselves
we may learn how to care for
[Music]
ourselves children nowadays are tyrants
they contradict their parents gobble
their food and tyrannize their
teachers the greatest blessings granted
to man kind come by way of Madness which
is a Divine
gift what screws us up the most in life
is the picture in our head of what it's
supposed to
be be of good cheer about death and know
this of a truth that no evil can happen
to a good man either in Life or after
death think not those faithful who
praise all thy words and actions but
those who kindly reprove thy
faults I only know that I know
nothing all men's souls are Immortal but
the souls of the righteous are Immortal
and
divine virtue does not come from wealth
but wealth and every other other good
thing which men have comes from
virtue through your Rags I see your
vanity the highest Realms of thought are
impossible to reach without first
attaining an understanding of
compassion to move the world we must
move
ourselves he who is unable to live in
society or he who has no need because he
is sufficient for himself must either be
a beast or a
[Music]
God not life but good life is to be
chiefly
valued wisdom begins in
wonder I know you won't believe me but
the highest form of Human Excellence is
to question oneself and
others the mind is everything what you
think you
become there is no solution seek it
lovingly the misuse of language induces
evil in the
soul living well and beautifully and
justly are all one
thing when you want wisdom and insight
as badly as you want to breathe it is
then you shall have
it there is no greater evil one can
suffer than to hate reasonable
discourse to express oneself badly is
not only faulty as far as language goes
but does harm to the soul
those who are hardest to love need love
the
most give me Beauty in my inward soul
may the outward and the inward man be
one it is better to change an opinion
than to persist in a wrong
one is it true is it kind is it
necessary he is not only Idol who does
nothing but he is Idol who might be
better
employed be true to thine own
self May the Inward and the outward man
be as
one are you not ashamed of caring so
much for the making of money and for
fame and Prestige when you neither think
nor care about wisdom and truth and the
Improvement of your
soul to know thyself is the beginning of
wisdom as to marriage or celibacy let a
man take which course he will he will be
sure to
repent a system of morality which is
based on relative emotional values is a
mere illusion a thoroughly vulgar
conception which has nothing sound in it
and nothing
[Music]
true beauty is a short-lived
tyranny wealth does not bring goodness
but goodness brings wealth and every
other blessing both to the individual
and to the
state my plainness of speech makes them
hate me and what is their hatred but a
proof that I am speaking the
truth true knowledge exists in knowing
that you know
nothing such as thy words are such will
thy affections be esteemed and such will
thy Deeds be as thy affections and such
thy life as thy
[Music]
Deeds an unconsidered life is not worth
living how many things can I do
without the only thing I know is that I
know
nothing trust not a woman when she weeps
for it is is her nature to weep when she
wants her
will as for me all I know is that I know
nothing for when I don't know what
Justice is I hardly know whether it is a
kind of virtue or not or whether a
person who has it is happy or
unhappy now the hour to part has come I
go to die you go to live which of us
goes to the better lot is known to No
One except to
God wisdom is knowing you know
nothing one thing only I know and that
is that I know
nothing